we humans are so complex but let's see I
agree with you this is why I live in is
not the truth no
no in reality is not no it's not it's
difficult to say no it's not it's not
hypocrite the reason I ask why you I I'm
assuming you only started believing what
you're saying quite recently I
personally I've never read I don't know
when I started believing it I think I've
always just grown up with like I said
15. okay I don't think I ever thought
about it okay I guess the conversation
is coming up a lot more of course and I
decided I'm not going to tell someone
how they feel I'm not going to do that
because what who am I to tell you that
you're not a woman wait
the same person you wanted to say that
this table is not circular in yellow
subjective we humans can't be objective
in every in everything that we do we
can't be objective we're too complex